>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nancy Groce: Hello my
name is Nancy Groce I am one
of the senior Folklife
specials here
at the American FolkLife Center
and I'd like to welcome you
to the latest presentation
of our ongoing Benjamin
Botkin lecture series.
The Botkin series allows
us to highlight the work
of leading scholars in the
disciplines of folklore,
ethnic musicology, oral
history and cultural heritage,
while enhancing the
collections here
at the American Folklife Center.
The center, and for the
center, and for the library,
the Botkin lectures
form an important facet
of our acquisitions activity.
Each lecture is videotaped
and becomes part
of the permanent collection
here at the center.
In addition, the lectures
are later posted as webcast
at the library's website
where they will be available
for viewing to Internet patrons
[phonetic] throughout the world.
So, if you haven't already done
so now would be an excellent
time to turn off cell phones
and anything else that
might beep and make noise.
So, today, I have the honor
of introducing the respected
folklorist researcher,
ethnomusicologist and
author, Jean Freedman.
Dr. Freedman received her PHD
in folklore and ethnomusicology
from Indiana University in 1995
and her first book "Whistling
in the Dark, Memory and
Culture in Wartime London",
[inaudible] popular culture
and political ideology
in London during World War II".
She's published on a
wide variety of topics,
including Scottish ballads,
Jewish folk theater,
an unconventional
Civil War soldiers.
Her writings have appeared
in numerous prestigious
publications including The New
York Times, The Washington Post,
The Journal of American
Folklore,
and Fast Folk Magazine.
She lives in Washington
DC area and she teaches
at Montgomery College and also
at George Washington University,
where I understand you'll
be teaching the course
on "Fairy Tales"
starting next week.
>> Jean R. Freedman: I
actually already started.
>> Nancy Groce: Already started?
OK, today she will be speaking
about her recent University
of Illinois publication,
"Peggy Seeger,
a Life of Music,
Love and Politics".
Jean first met Peggy in 1979
during a junior year abroad
in London and she
frequented the Singers Club,
a legendary folk club run
by Peggy and her partner
and husband Ewan MacColl.
Although much has been
written about other members
of the Seeger family, several
years ago, Jean realized
that Peggy's involvements in
and contributions to the world
of folk music, in the folk
music revival had been
under documented.
So, her highly readable new
biography should address this
oversight, in some very good
read, Jean was in close touch
with Peggy when researching
and writing this book,
and she also may
considerable use
of the significant collections
on the Seeger family material.
We are proud here to have
her here at the library,
both in the American
Folklife Center
and in the music division,
and we are always delighted
to feature Botkin
much you have made use
of library resources
and archives.
Anyhow, I'll let her tell
you more about Peggy Seeger.
Let me just close by reminding
you that we do have copies
of Jean's book for sale in the
four yard, and she will be happy
to sign them immediately
after her talk.
So, what please join me in
making welcome Jean Freedman.
[ Applause ]
>> Jean R. Freedman:
Thank you Nancy and thanks
to everyone here at
the Library of Congress
for making this possible and
thanks to all of you for coming.
Can you hear me?
OK. All right.
Well, I'm going to start off
by building on what Nancy said
about how I first met Peggy
because that is usually
the first question,
I'm asked when people hear
that I've written a
biography of Peggy Seeger.
So, I'm just going to read a
little bit from the preface.
I first met Peggy Seeger
on an autumn evening
in London in 1979.
The setting was the Singers
Club, a folk club that Peggy
and her husband, Ewan McColl
had begun in the early 1960s.
I was in London,
studying theater
through the most
American of adventures:
the junior year abroad.
Having grown up in a much
smaller city, I was entranced
by the cultural offerings
it only a major metropolis
can afford.
But on that October evening,
I was still a newcomer
and a stranger, a long
way from home and amused
by cultural differences
I had never anticipated.
I didn't know my shoe size
or the proper way
to buy vegetables.
The cars were unfamiliar and
they drove on the wrong side
of the street and I needed a new
vocabulary for ordinary things,
lift, over jean, petrol,
chemist shop, surgical spirit,
translated into American that
is elevator, eggplant, gasoline,
pharmacy and rubbing alcohol.
I'd never seen Peggy before,
but her accent was familiar
and she sang the songs I knew,
The Single Girl and
Jenny Jenkins.
After the performance, I
introduced myself and said,
"Thank you for taking me home".
Throughout that long
an extraordinary year,
the Singers Club became an
essential part of my routine.
In a small room above Bloomsbury
pub, I could hear some
of Britain's finest folk
musicians for a price
of 50 Pence, and anyone who
wanted to could sing a song
from the floor in the
middle of the evening.
I particular looked forward
to the nights when Ewan
and Peggy sang, I loved their
unique combination of old
and new music, 18th
century ballads
and 19th century sea shanties
mixed with musical polemics
about apartheid or
Margaret Thatcher.
I loved their combination
of musical skill,
intellectual rigor
and political clarity.
I joined the committee
that round the Singers Club
in at our first committee
meeting, Ewan begin telling me
of his days in the theater.
When I indicated my
interest in hearing more,
Ewan and Peggy invited me
to dinner at their home
where we ate, talked and
sang long into the night.
Ewan and Peggy's influence
on my life is perhaps
greater than they knew.
After my year in London, I
returned to the United States
and completed my
degree in theater.
Then I moved to New York, where
I found myself spending more
and more time with folk music.
Singing, writing songs, helping
to run a small folk club
in Greenwich Village.
In 1988, I began graduate work
and folklore in ethnomusicology
at Indiana University.
My PhD dissertation was a study
of London during World War II.
Once again, I spent
a year in London.
But the Singers Club
no longer existed
and the folk music community,
still creative and vibrant,
was very different from
the one I had known.
Time passes.
In the 1990s, a friend from
the New York City folk revival,
put Peggy and me in
contact via email.
A friend from graduate school
asked me to review a book
about Peggy's mother,
Ruth Crawford Seegar
for the Journal of
American Folklore.
I had questions about the book
and emailed them to Peggy.
She preferred to discuss
the matter by telephone.
In the course of
our conversation,
she asked if I knew
anyone who was interested
in writing her biography.
I suggested myself.
Six months later, we saw
each other for the first time
in years when she visited my
home in Montgomery County,
Maryland, only a few miles
from where she grew up.
Our work is biographer
and subject had begun.
So that was the beginning.
Now, Peggy was born
in New York City 1935,
live there for six months
before moving to the Washington,
DC area, and her parents
were very influential
on her life in many ways.
This is a photograph of
the Seeger family at home,
there's -- reading
from left to right --
her mother, Ruth Crawford
Seeger, her sister Barbara,
her father Charles
Seeger, her sister Penny,
her brother Mike Seeger,
and then Peggy herself.
Now, her father, had
begun as a composer,
and then later became
an academic.
And her mother also
began as a composer
and later also became a
folk song anthologized.
She transcribed and
arranged folksongs
for many people,
including Ben Botkin.
And Peggy in fact, learned
how to transcribe when working
for her mother, transcribing
songs
for Ben Botkin's Treasury
of Western Folklor.
So, there's a very
strong connection
between Botkin and the Seeger's.
They move to Washington, so that
Charles could take up a post
with the New Deal and he
held a variety of positions
in the government service for
several years, doing all sorts
of activities to
do with folk music.
These included: collecting
folksongs, publishing them.
He started out in the
resettlement administration
in which there were these new
communities that had been formed
by people who had been
displaced by the depression,
and Charles's job was to use
music to create some kind
of cohesion, and community
spirit, in these communities.
And the Seeger's met
Botkin fairly early on,
he was also employed by the
New Deal, he was working
for the Federal Writers Project
and they became not only
coworkers, but personal friends.
And I suggest that it is
largely through their influence
that the idea of folk music
that we have today as sort
of progressive left liberal
notion of folk music,
was promulgated initially by
the Seeger's and by Botkin.
And it was in contradistinction
really do an older idea folk
music which is become common
in the early decades
of the 20th century.
An idea that that folk
music was essentially rural,
it was essentially conservative,
it was resistant to change.
And the people who were involved
in what's often called the first
folk revival, used folk music
in a very, very conservative
fashion, very nationalistic,
frequently racist,
frequently anti-semitic.
And in the 30s people
such as the Seeger's,
[inaudible] said,
"This is all wrong.
This is not what folk
music should be used for".
I'm going to read just very
briefly, from the book: I say,
"they argued for a vision
of America more diverse
and progressive than had
here to fore been known,
an America in which
the cultures of rural
and urban communities were
valorized, the contributions
of immigrants, workers
and minorities celebrated.
Botkin's Treasury
of American Folklore
for which Charles Seeger
served as music consultant,
contains a strongly worded
denunciation of those
who view folklore in
terms of racial heritage,
or insist that a
particular folk group or body
of tradition is superior
or pure".
So, this is the atmosphere
that Peggy grew up in.
An atmosphere in which
music is always present,
her parents were
always playing music.
They were always singing.
Her mother had songs that
accompanied every activity,
she said she knew
it's time to go to bed
when her mother started
playing Cindy on the piano,
and when it was time to wash
dishes they would all get
together in the kitchen and one
person would lead the singing
and that would be the accompany
meant for the activity.
It was not a real surprised
when both Peggy and her brother,
Mike became, not only
interested in folk music,
but became proficient in it
by the time they
were in their teens.
Now, the second question I
get asked when people find
out that I've written a
biography of Peggy Seeger is
"is she related to Pete?
And the answer is, yes, Charles
Seeger had been married before
and had three sons
by his first wife
of which Pete is the youngest.
This is a picture taken
during World War II,
and there you see private
Pete Seeger with Peggy
and her younger sister Barbara.
Now, in the fall
of 1953 a number
of very important things
happened in Peggy's life.
One is she started college
at Ratcliff [phonetic],
and the second thing
that happened was much less
happy, her mother died.
Ruth Crawford Seeger had cancer.
She died far too young.
And she had been
the main breadwinner
for the family for
several years.
She -- most of the
money that came in,
was earned by Ruth
as a piano teacher.
So, Peggy was concerned,
as a college freshman,
that she might not have enough
money to continue college.
Since her father had to
support the other children,
support the household, he might
not have money for tuition.
So, she was talking to a couple
of her friends in Boston.
This was sort of the springtime
of the mid-century folk revival.
She had a lot of friends,
who were involved
in the folk revival.
And they said to her, "Why
don't you make an album?
If you need money, why
not make an album?"
And so, she did.
And her first album, collection
of love songs call "Folk Songs
of Courting and Complaint",
they are all traditional,
all but one is American.
And I'm going to play
just a little bit of one
of these songs, "hen First
Unto This Country a Stranger,
I came".
[ Music ]
OK. So, that's her early
voice very pure very lovely,
relatively anonymous.
It could had belong to
any talented young singer.
So, she made this, so she
was able to continue college.
Her father and sisters
moved up to Boston
so they could all be together
and there be only one household
to support, and then at the end
of her sophomore year her
father remarried and moved
to California with his new wife,
taking the younger
girls with him.
Peggy didn't really want to
stay in Boston on her own.
She considered briefly going
to college in California,
but she ended up going
in the opposite direction
and spending some time with
her brother Charles the third.
Technically her half-brother,
Charles Seeger's eldest son,
at the university of life,
where he was a professor.
So, she moved to Leiden
in the autumn of 1955.
But she didn't stay there very
long, her initial plan was
to study Russian in
the language of Dutch,
which was challenging
and interesting.
But, she was never
far from folk music.
So, towards the end of the year
a friend of her's from home,
who been studying at the London
School of Economics showed
up in Leiden and said,
"How'd you like to hitch hike
around Europe" and
she said, "sure".
So, they were hitchhiking
around Europe in December,
and it was cold and there
was no central heating
and they were picked up by a
Belgium Catholic priest named
Joseph Lousberg.
Who is with a bunch of students
from the University of Leuven
in Belgium and they
were going to Germany
to present a Christmas play in
German, and they asked Peggy
and her friend if
they wanted to join.
Because what does a German
Christmas play really need?
It needs a banjo.
[ Laughter ]
So, they said, "sure".
And they went to Germany,
they did the play
in German in Berlin.
Peggy's friend went back to
London and Peggy returned
to Belgium with this Catholic
priest and a couple of the kids
who they had met in Berlin
and stayed there for a while.
Went back to Leiden for a while
and then she got a phone call
from an old family
friend: Alan Lomax.
And he said, "how'd you
like to come to London,
I am starting a folk group and
we are going to do a production
of dark of the moon and
I think there are lots
of things that you could do.
We need a banjo player, no one
in England plays the banjo.
So, can you come to London?"
And initially she said, "no".
She said "I'm going
Scandinavians,
friends that I met
on the boat coming
over to Europe have
invited me to go with them.
I said 'yes', I have
a commitment.
And besides I don't
have any money.
I can't afford to
come to London".
But Alan's persistent.
He was nothing if not
persistent and he said, "OK,
you can wait a few weeks, you
fulfill your commitment to go
to Scandinavia and I'll send you
the money to come to London".
And she said "all
right, why not?
Sounds like an adventure".
So, she arrived in London on
the morning of March 27th 1956.
She had been on the
train all night.
Now, you know how you
look when you have been
on the train all night?
You know how you
feel when you've been
on the train all night?
That's how she felt and looked.
Allen met her at Waterloo
Station, gave her a big hug
and said, "you got an interview.
So, not an interview, an
audition, this morning
with this group of singers
that I want you to play with".
Alan's girlfriend at the time
was a model, she took one look
at Peggy and started doing a
makeover on her, giving her lots
of makeup, doing her hair
in a beehive, giving her one
of those 1950s outfits
that looked like that.
And Peggy went out and saying
for this group of musicians,
and they thought
she was wonderful.
Particularly one, his
name was Ewan McColl.
So, Peggy joined The Ramblers,
which is the name
of the folk group.
They did concerts,
they did albums.
They did this production of
Dark of the Moon and to hear you
until the story, he
fell in love with her.
The minute he saw her, but
there were a number of problems
in their relationship.
One was that he was 20
years older than she was,
and another one with the he
was married to somebody else.
So, Peggy said, "I
can't handle this.
I'm going to go back
to the States".
So, she went back to California
stayed with her father,
but they stayed in touch.
And Peggy being Peggy
continue doing concerts.
And one day she and Ewan
were talking on the phone.
Now, that sounds completely
unremarkable to as now
that someone in California would
be talking to someone in London.
But, in the 50s this was very
rare, was very expensive.
You tended to limit your
calls to three minutes
because in every three minutes
block, you had to pay more money
and during the course of their
conversation, Peggy said,
"I got a concert coming up and
they want a new short love song
and I can't think of one.
Do you have one?
Do you know of one I could use?"
And he said, "well, I'm
sure I can write one"
and put together this song
on the spot on the phone.
[ Music ]
So, that was the song, she
sang it, it was well received.
She then got a gig playing at
the Guetto Horn in Chicago,
which was one of the mayor
first major folk clubs.
And then you would
encourage her to go
to the World Youth Festival in
Russia, which was a gathering
of people, young people
from all over the world.
Left wing organizations had
begun the World Youth Festival
shortly after the
end of World War II,
and actually the one she
attended with the largest
of the World Youth
Festival gatherings.
So, she went.
She met a young Californian,
whom she had actually known
before at her parents' house,
Guy Carawan, and the two
of them gave a number
of concerts together in Russia.
I don't know if you can see it.
But if you look very, very
closely at this photograph,
you can see the hammers and
sickles on the curtains.
And so, she and the rest
of the American delegation
gave a number of concerts
and then the American delegation
was invited to go to China.
Now, this was 1957, America
had no diplomatic relations
with China and everyone in
the American delegation, was,
got an individual telegram
from the State Department.
This was John Foster Dulles
State Department, saying,
"if you go to China,
you will be considered
to be a willing [inaudible]
in this propaganda,
working against the
interests of the United States
and when you come back
home, you maybe fined,
you may lose your passport,
you may even be put in jail".
Now, this is pretty
serious business,
this is the height
of the Cold War.
And so, most for the people in
the American delegation decided
that they had better not take
a chance, that they were going
to heat State Department's
warnings, and not go.
But, Peggy and Guy
Carawan, and his wife Noel,
and a few other people,
about 40 other people decided
that they were going
to go to China.
When would they get another
opportunity like that.
And there's a picture
of Peggy in China.
Now, when she left China, she
actually went back to Russia
for a while and she
didn't want to go back home
because she had been warned
that she might lose her passport
and if she lost her passport
that meant she'd be stuck
in America and she wouldn't
be able to see Ewan MacColl.
Their relationship at this point
was sort of a state of flux.
She didn't know quite what
was going on, so she decided
that she was going to stay in
Europe for as long as possible.
She stayed for a while in
Paris, staying with a friend
of Ralph Rinzler, who, I'm
sure you know the name,
became one of this country's
most distinguished folklorist
are the Smithsonian
Folklife Festival.
At the time was a student
studying French in Paris.
And she got a work permit
to enter England briefly,
not permanently, but
long enough to work
on what were called
radio ballades.
Now, these were a particularly
innovative radio documentaries
that she and Ewan MacColl,
and Charles Parker produced.
And what they did is they went
around and interviewed people
and then they created songs
based on the interviews
and they also used the actual
words of the interviewees
which was very new,
it was extremely
revolutionary technique.
BBC wasn't quite sure
if it was going to work.
But, it ended up
working very nicely.
The first radio ballads called
"The Ballad of John Axon".
It was about a train
engineer who had died sort
of like a captain going
down with his ship there
was a train malfunction
and he had stuck with
it, do it till the end.
The third radio ballad,
which is one
of the best known called
Singing The Fishing,
won a very prestigious
prize, The [inaudible].
So, they continued working
on these radio ballads
of throughout the, the
late 50s and early 60s.
But Peggy could only
initially, while she was working
on the radio ballad, she
could only go to England
for a brief period of time
on this special work visa,
then she'd go back to France.
And she and Ewan decided that
they did want to stay together,
they did want to live together,
so they had this problem
to solve, and then
something happens that sort
of accelerated the process
of them deciding what to do.
Peggy got pregnant.
So, they had to figure out
some way that she could get
to England and stay there.
Now, the easiest way is to
marry a British subject,
but at this point,
Ewan was still married
to his second wife.
They had a friend, a Scottish
folk singer by the name
of Alex Campbell, who in
what I consider an absolutely
extraordinary gesture
of friendship said,
"I'll marry you".
And so, when Peggy was
about six months pregnant,
they were married in Paris.
The priest, giving
Alex Campbell,
a dirty look the whole time,
and later on gave
him a stern dressing
down for getting this young
woman in trouble and waiting
so long to make an
honest woman of her,
but it fulfilled its
bureaucratic purpose.
She was able to go to England
and she immediately
could get citizenship.
Because she was married
to a British subject,
and then sometime later, she
and Alex Campbell had
a nice quiet divorce.
So, 1959 Peggy moved to
England and lived with Ewan.
Also in that year their
first son Neil was born.
1963 their son Calum was born
and that's a picture of the four
of them at the Singers Club.
All right, now I want to
give you some examples
of the different kinds
of music that Peggy does
because she is very
prolific, she can do all sort
of different genres,
different varieties of music.
First thing, I am going
to play you a little bit
of a traditional Scotts folk
song that she sang with Ewan
and called "The Spinning Wheel".
One of the many things that
I love about this song is
that in common with
many Scots folksongs,
it has a heroine named Jean.
[ Music ]
So, that's a love song in which
the man is courting the woman
and she continues to
spin her spinning wheel
until the very end in which
she says, "what I learned?
I like to [inaudible] wheel far
better than my spinning wheel".
Up until this point, Peggy had
done mainly traditional songs,
mainly American.
She started singing Scott songs
and English songs with Ewan.
But in the late 50s she started
writing songs of her own,
and the first one that
really got attention
with called the Ballad of Spring
Hill, and it was about an event
that happened in 58 near the
town of Springhill, Nova Scotia,
where there was an underground
earthquake that caused a mine
to collapse, and a number of the
miners were killed immediately.
The others were eventually
rescued, took about a week.
And it became very well-known
because it was the first
of this kind of disaster
to be televised.
So, Peggy heard about it when
she was still living in France,
and she wrote this song in
traditional ballad format,
but telling this
very modern story.
I'm going to play
just a little bit
of the Ballad of Spring Hill.
[ Music ]
OK, and another thing
that both Peggy and Ewan
and became very well-known for
was writing political music,
writing topical songs
about events.
And in 1960 they brought
out this album called the
"New Britain Gazette", which was
composed entirely of new songs.
Again, that's something that
we think of unremarkable
for folksingers to be
politically minded.
But, except for Peggy's
brother Pete,
this was relatively unusual, so
this was very much a new thing,
and Peggy wrote "The Crooked
Cross" after a campaign
in London, a political campaign,
in which a man named Oswald
Mosley was running for office.
Now, Oswald Mosley was a
fascist, genuine fascist,
big F. During the
wars, he had been part
of an organization called
the British Union Fascist.
And he was running
for office in 1959.
His followers plastered
London with swastikas,
which was of course
"The Crooked Cross",
and Peggy wrote this
song in response.
[ Music ]
So, by the early 60s, Ewan
and Peggy were becoming known
as the primary folksingers in
England, and there was a group
of young folk singers who wanted
to learn more about singing,
and about songs and
writing songs.
And so, Ewan and Peggy
got together this group,
which they named
The Critics Group.
And, this was a group of young
singers who would meet weekly
at Ewan and Peggy's house and
they would get instruction
on how to sing, how
to write songs
and they also did quite
a number of projects.
Together they did
albums, they did concerts.
And one of the most innovative
things they did was a kind
of folk theater called
The Festival of Fools.
Now, The Festival of Fools was
originally a medieval festival
done in Europe in which
people on the, the lower runs
of social hierarchy make fun
of people on the upper runs
of the social hierarchy.
And this appealed to them,
so they decided it was time
to revive this tradition.
And what they did is they would
go through the newspapers,
month by month, collecting items
of news that were interesting,
horrifying, funny, engaging,
in some way dramatic,
and they wrote songs about them,
and they made sketches
about them.
And then at the end of the year,
they performed this as sort
of a musical revue called
The Festival of Fools
and they did this from the,
the mid 60s to the early 70s.
It was very well received,
it became very well known,
and then in 1971, they used to
have this, the first stirrings
of what we now called the
second wave of feminism,
and Ewan wrote most of
the script of The Festival
of Fools presentations.
Peggy wrote a lot of the songs.
She also did the musical
direction, she also acted, sang,
played instruments, did
most of the organizing.
So, she had a lot to do,
and then in 1971, Ewan said,
"I think we need a women song
in this year's production.
I think you should
write a women's song".
Peggy had a quite enough to
do as it was, but she decided,
"Yes, that was a good idea".
And she wrote what is often
considered for most famous song
"I'm going to be an engineer".
[ Music ]
OK, yes, then that is still
her, her most famous song.
She still has people
coming up to her, saying,
"I became an engineer because
of you" or then it was,
"my daughter became an
engineer", but now it's,
"my granddaughter became an
engineer because of you".
And she and Ewan
continued to play, sing,
write songs about
all sorts of issues.
In the 80s Peggy got involved
with quite a number
of new issues.
One of them was the women's
Peace Camp at Greenham Com,
and where she went periodically.
She also got very involved with
the environmental movement,
and that remains
one of her passions.
One of the things that
she continues to sing
and write songs about.
And then, in the middle of the
decade was the miners' strike
in Britain and she and Ewan
were also very involved
in the miners' strike.
So, they continued being
up to the minute political
topical song writers throughout
the 80s.
Then in 1989 Ewan McCall died,
and Peggy got a lot of solace
from a friend of
hers, Irene Scott,
someone she had known
for many years.
And after Ewan died, Irene
was them very often the person
that she turned to.
And then, they fell in love,
and here's a song,
she wrote about that.
[ Music ]
So, after Ewan died,
it became difficult
for Peggy to stay in England.
Everything there reminded her
of Ewan, and she also found
that she and Ewan had been
considered such a musical unit
that it became difficult for
her to get bookings without him,
there was one man in particular,
a particular horrible person
who referred to her as a
"remnant of a dead duo".
Yes. So, she decided she
would like to move back
to the States for a while.
She was, after all, a
specialist in American folk song
and that remained her specialty
throughout the time she lived
in England, because she
felt, "this is my culture,
these are the songs
of my country
in this is what I can do best".
But, she hadn't lived in in
America for nearly 35 years.
So, she moved back to America
initially to Asheville,
North Carolina, which is the,
the seedbed to a lot of the song
that she sang, it was the place
that her father visited during
his work for the New Deal,
visited some of,
the festivals there.
It was a place where
her brother Pete,
first heard the five
strings banjo.
So, it was definitely
a very meaningful place
for her to go to.
And she lived there for 12
years, and then moved to Boston
to teach song writing at
Northeastern University in 2006.
And stay there for four years,
continuing to write songs
and continuing to make
albums of traditional music.
She never lost her roots,
she was always someone
who had one foot in the
traditional camp and one foot
in the contemporary camp, and
who was equally adept at both.
And then, in 2010 she
moved back to England
and settled in Oxford.
Her children and her
grandchildren lived
in the London area, so
Oxford is very nearby.
And the last thing I am going to
play for you is a song she wrote
for her brother Pete's
94th birthday.
Now, let me see if I remember
how to get out of this.
So, this is the song that she
wrote for Pete's 94 birthdays
[ Music ]
Just had the pleasure to play
all that, it's so delightful.
OK, so we're almost
up to the present.
Peggy made her, the most recent
album she made was in 2014.
It's called "Everything Changes"
and it's a very different album
from the kind of things that
she had done previously.
And she's now planning a new
album to go along with the tour
that she's doing in the autumn,
and that's not bad
for an 82-year-old.
I spoke to her last summer.
I remember, she had
just finished the tour
and she said -- I'm tired
and I need to take a break.
I've just had this tour
throughout England --
and I said -- OK, so
what are you going to do?
-- She said -- well, Irene
and I are going to go
on a three week safari
in Africa -- .
So, that's how she relaxes.
Well. Thank you very much,
does anyone have any questions?
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
That's something that's
not entirely clear,
I know she didn't want
to initially, they,
and so it took a while
to get a divorce.
They eventually did
divorce and eventually Ewan
and Peggy did marry, but exactly
how it happened is something I
have never figured out.
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
Interesting.
That's a good question.
I really don't know they, The
State Department's take on that.
I do know that, a lot of
folksingers, particularly Pete,
was viewed with a certain
amount of suspicion.
In fact, one the reasons that
Charles Seeger, the third was
in Leiden, and not
the United States is
that he couldn't get a
job in the United States,
not because he wasn't a
good enough scientist,
but because he couldn't
pass the security clearance.
He'd been offered a plumb job
at, I believe it was MIT on,
but the interview
consisted largely of,
"tell me about the
politics of Pete and Peggy".
So, they were very much,
under the, they were very much
on the radar of the
powers that be,
how much they were
actually being followed
by the State Department,
I don't know.
It's a good question.
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
Yes. That's a good question.
I mean, Peggy always does
what she thinks is right,
and you know if there
are consequences,
there are consequences.
But, I know in the
in the early 60s,
she and Ewan had planned this
major tour of the United States
and at the last minute,
Ewan didn't get a visa,
he was considered too
much of a security threat.
So, she had to do
the tour by herself.
So, I know that was one thing.
England, was under less
of a of a red scare.
So, I think it was, it was
less of a problem there.
But certainly, coming here
it could be a problem.
Definitely.
Yes? Nancy.
[ Inaudible question ]
That's a huge question.
She was a great influence and
in fact, the American folk rival
in some ways jump started
the British folk revival,
then they had took great pains
to differentiate themselves
from the American folk revival.
But, before a number of
Americans came there,
including Alan Lomax and Peggy
Seeger, the main folk music,
the idea was sort of the Cecil
Sharp early 20th century,
Maypoles peasants dancing
in the village green idea,
and people who were
interested in this kind
of music took their inspiration
from Leadbelly and
Woody Guthrie.
And started a movement called
skiffle, which was in many ways,
a sort of attempt to do the
songs of Guthrie on Leadbelly
in England, using
particular instruments,
washboard base and
things like that.
Then, Alan came along doing
lots of folk music of projects
and brought Peggy over,
and because she was
such a skilled musician and
because the music she did was
so exciting, that a lot of
people in Britain said, "hey,
I want to get involved in this".
The American folk revival
was doing very well,
records were selling well and
were being played on the radio,
and so a lot of a British
people started singing American
folk songs.
And there was actually an
incident that took place
at the Singers' Club in which
someone was singing a Leadbelly
song, I can't remember
which one,
but singing in the very
strong cockney accent
and Peggy just fell
on the floor laughing.
She thought it was so funny.
And people were saying "that
wasn't a very nice thing to do,
laugh at this person's
performance", she says,
"but I know Leadbelly, I know
how he is supposed to sound
like and that's not it".
So, the Singers' Club
instituted a policy,
which lasted till the
end of the Singers' Club,
that if you sang a
song in that club,
you sang the songs
of your own culture.
So, that if you were English
you sang English songs.
If you were Scott,
you, sang Scott songs.
And so, a lot of
people in Britain,
then started looking
toward their own music
and started saying.
"hey, we got folk
music to, we don't have
to just be imitating
the Americans.
We can sing the songs of our own
culture", so she had I think,
she had a great influence
on the folk revival there,
and continues to do so.
She's sort of the
elder stateswoman
of the folk revival there now.
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
Yes. It's interesting.
Good catch, she does, this is
something I discuss in the book,
I didn't actually
discuss it with her.
But, she read everything
I wrote so --
and she made comments
and if she didn't
like something she'd
let me know.
So, she didn't make a
negative comment about that,
so she apparently approved.
But in "Love Unbidden", she
takes some of the language
from first time ever and
uses it, and uses it in sort
of interesting ways, like in
first time ever, he has talking
about the trembling heart of
a captive bird that was there
at my command, in
a "Love Unbidden",
she talks about being a wild
bird instead of a captive bird,
she is a wild bird that
is at your command.
So, it's a very,
very different idea,
but using a similar structure
and she uses the same
structure beginning every stanza
with approximately the same
line with minor revisions.
So, it's yes, it's very
definitely taken off
of first time ever.
And, one of, there's one
scholar has a quote in the book
who noticed that she in the
first in "Love Unbidden",
she talks at, I am on one of
those who dare not claim thee.
And she says that this
sounds like the love
that dare not speak its name,
which is on that what was the
phrase, it became famous at,
at Oscar Wilde's trial
for homosexuality.
But very subtle.
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
Sure, she recorded for lots
of different record labels,
go to her website and you'll
see that there are maybe 20.
But yes, she recorded for
Folkways, she recorded for DECA,
she recorded on the
On-Topic Folk Lyric, Rounder.
She and Ewan founded their own
company, Blackthorn Records,
she did a number
of records on that.
Apple Seeds.
It just loads and
loads of different --
wherever they could
do the kind of music
that the wanted and
could get it out.
Good question.
Yes.
[ Inaudible question ]
I know a little bit, she's
planning to do a similar
to her most recent album, which
is a much more contemporary,
it has a much more
contemporary sound.
It's really her.
I was talking with her
daughter in law, who said,
"this isn't a folk album this
is a Signer's songwriter album".
And it's true in a
lot of her albums,
it could it have been
a live recording.
It could it just been sort
of like the old-fashioned way
that music technology was,
so this is to record
live performance.
Her latest album is
not like that at all,
is full of sampled sound.
It's full of music that
could only have been done
in a recording studio
and it's full of,
of jazz inflected accompaniment,
lots of international
instruments and also,
writing in a much less
traditional style,
so that's what she is planning
to do for her next album.
I'll be eager to see it.
Anybody else?
All right, well, thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of The Library
of Congress, visit
us at loc.gov.